>> Okay Michael, so we've done our little
example. I want to ask you a quick question
and try to talk something through with you
and then we can start to wrap up. Okay.
>> Awesome.
>> Alright, so, here is my quick question. Now, in the reading, which I know
you've read, there's a proof. That shows that boosting not
only, you know, does pretty things with axis of line semi-planes, but also
that it will converge to good answers and that it will
find good combined hypotheses. You know, we could go look at
the reading and write down a proof that shows that boosting
does well. Umm. And there's one in the reading. Or we
could talk about an intuition. So if someone were to come
up to you. If a student were to find you somewhere
and said, I read the proof, I'm kind of getting it,
but do you have a good sort of intuition about why
boosting tends will do well? What do you think you would tell them?
Could you think of something simple? I've been struggling with this for a while.
>> No. [LAUGH].
>> Okay, well, then let me try something on you and you can tell
me if it sort of makes sense. So this is just an intuition for why,
for why boosting pins will do well. Okay, so what does boosting do? Okay.
Boosting basically says, if I have some
examples that I haven't been able to classify
well, I'm going to re-rate all my examples. So that the ones
I don't do well become increasingly
important. Right, that's what boosting does. Yes?
>> Yes.
>> Right, that's what this whole, whole bit of D is all about. It's all about
re-weighting based on difficulty and hardest. And we know that
we have the notion of a weak learner. That no matter what happens for
whatever distribution, we're always going to be able to find
some hypothesis that does well. So, if I'm trying to
understand why boosting in the end, why the final hypothesis
that I get at the end, is going to do well.
I can try to get a feeling for that by
asking, well. Under what circumstances would it not do well? So,
if it doesn't do well, then that means there has
to be a bunch of examples that it's getting wrong, right?
>> Mm hm.
>> That's what it would mean not to do well, agreed?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So how many things could it not get right? How many things could it
misclassify? How many things could it get incorrect?
Well, I'm going to argue Michael, that, that
number has to be small. There cannot be a lot of examples that it gets wrong.
So do you want to know why? Do you want to know my reasoning for why?
>> Yeah.
>> So, here's my reasoning, let's imagine I had a
number of examples at the end of this whole process.
I've done it T times. I've gone through this many times
and I have some number of examples that I'm getting
wrong. If I were getting those examples wrong, then I was
getting them wrong in the last time step, right? And,
since I have a distribution and I re-normalize, and it has
to be the case that at least half of the time,
more than half of the time I am correct, that number
of things I'm getting wrong has to be getting smaller over
time. Because let's imagine that was at a stage where I
had a whole bunch of them wrong. Well, then I would
naturally renormalize them with a distribution so that all of those things
are important. But if they were all important, the ones that
I was getting wrong, the next time I run a learner, I
am going to have to get at least half of them
right, more than half of them are right. Is that make sense?
>> It does, but it, but what scares me is, okay, why can't
it just be the case that the previous ones which were getting right
start to get more wrong as we shift our energy towards the errors.
>> Yeah, why is that?
>> I don't know. But did you wanna, are we, we working up to some kind of you
know, log n kind of thing where each time
you are knocking off half of them and therefore.
>> I don't know. Do you remember the proof.
>> The proof.
>> I mean what goes on is that
you get, sort of, this exponentially aggressive weighting over
examples, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And you're driving down the number of things you get wrong. Sort of
exponentially quickly, over time. That's why boosting
works so well and works so fast.
>> I get that we're, the we're quickly ramping up the weights on the hard
ones. I don't get why that's causing us to get fewer things wrong over time.
So like, when you should, in your, in your example that you worked through, that
had the error in the alphas and the errors kept going down and the alphas
kept going up.
>> Right.
>> Like, is that necessarily the case?
>> Well, what would be the circumstances under
which it isn't the case? How would you
ever go back and forth between examples? Well,
certainly it's the case that if you keep getting
something, right, you will, get them. Well, so
here's what happens over time, right. Is that over
time, every new hypothesis, it gets to get
a vote, based upon how well it does on
the last, difficult let's say, distribution. So the
ones that are even if the ones that
you were getting right you start to get
wrong, they are going to, if you get them
increasingly wrong, that error's going to go down and
you're going to get less of a vote, right.
Because e sub T is over the current
distribution. And it's not over the sum of the
voted, over all the examples you've ever seen.
>> Understand.
>> So does that make sense? Is that right?
>> I don't know. I don't have the intuition, it seems like
it could be, you know, could we keep shifting the distribution. It
could be that the error is going up. Like if the error
could be low, why can't we just make it low from the beginning.
>> Right.
>> Like, I feel like the error should be going up,
because we're, we're asking it harder and harder questions as we go.
>> No, no, no, because we're asking it harder and
harder questions, but even though we're
asking it harder and harder questions, it's
forced to be able to do well on those hard questions. It's forced
to, because it's a weak learner. I mean that's why having, being able
to always, that's why having a weak learner is such a powerful thing.
>> But why couldn't we like on, on
iteration 17, have something where the weak learner works
right at the edge of it's abilities, and
it just comes back with something that's a half
minus epsilon.
>> That's fine. But it has to always be able to do that. If it's
a half minus epsilon, the things it's getting
wrong will have to go back down again.
>> No, no I understand that. What I'm saying
is that, why would the error go down each iteration.
>> Well, it doesn't have to, but it shouldn't be getting bigger.
>> Why shouldn't it be getting bigger?
>> So, imagine, imagine, imagine the case that you're
getting, right. You, you are working at the edge of
your abilities. You get half of them right. Roughly and
half of them wrong, the ones you got wrong would
become more important, so the next time round you're going
to get those right, versus the other ones. So you could
cycle back and forth I suppose, in the worst case,
but then you're just going to be sitting around, always having
a little bit more information. So your error will not
get worse, you'll just have different ones that are able to
vote on that do well on different parts of the space.
Right? Because you're always forced to do better than chance. So.
>> Yeah but that, that's not the same as saying
that we're forced to get better and better each iteration.
>> That's right, it's not.
>> So it's, yeah again, I don't see that, that property just falling out.
>> Well, I don't see it falling out either, but then
I haven't read the proof in like seven, eight, nine years.
>> Well, I feel like it should be, it should be something like, look we
had, look at what the, so okay, so we generate a new distribution, what is
the previous, what's the previous classified error
on this distribution, it better be the case.
I mean if it were the case that we always return the best classifier that
I could imagine trying to use that but.
>> Well we, well we don't, we don't require that.
>> Yeah, I mean, it's just finding one
that's epsilon minus, or a half minus epsilon.
>> Right, so let's, let's see if we can take the simple case,
we got three examples, right, and you're bouncing back and forth and you want
to construct something so that you always do well on two of them.
And then poorly on one, kind of a thing, and that you keep bouncing
back and forth. So let's imagine that you have one-third, one-third, one-third,
and your first thing gets the first two right and the last one
wrong. So you have an error of a third. And you make that
last one more likely and the other two less likely. Suitably normalized, right?
>> Yep.
>> So now, your next one, you want to somehow
bounce back and have it decide that it can miss,
so let's say you missed the third one. So you,
you get the third one right. You get the second
one right but you get the first one wrong. What's going
to happen? Well, three is going to go down. You're still going to,
well you won't have a third error actually. You'll have less than
a third error because you had to get one of the ones
you were getting right wrong, you had to get the one
you were getting wrong right. So your error is going to be
at least an example I just gave. Less than a third. So,
if your error is less and a third, then the weighting goes
up more. And so, the one that you just got wrong
goes up, doesn't go back to where it was before. It
becomes even more important than it was when you had a
uniform distribution. So the next time around, you have to get
that one right, but it's not enough to break a half.
So you're going to have to get something else right as well,
and the one in the middle that you were getting right
isn't enough. So you'll have to get number three right as well.
>> Interesting.
>> Right? And so, it's really hard to cycle
back and forth between different examples, because you're exponentially
weighting how important they are. Which means, you're always
going to have to pick up something along the way.
Because the ones that you, coicidentally, got right two
times in a row. Become so unimportant. It doesn't
help you to get those right. Whereas, the ones
that you've gotten wrong, in the past. You've got to,
on these cycles. Pick up some of them in order to get you over a half.
>> Mmm
>> And so, it is very difficult for you to cycle back and forth.
>> Interesting.
>> And that kind of makes sense, right? If
you think about it in kind of an information gain
sense, because what's going on there is you're, you're
basically saying you must pick up information all the time.
>> Hm. And then your non uni. Well uniform is
the wrong word but you are kind of. You know,
non-linearly using that information in some way. So that kind of
works. It makes some sense to me, but I think that
in the end what has to happen is you. You, there
must be just a few examples in a kind of weighted sense
that you're getting wrong. And so if I'm right, that as
you, as you move through each of these cycles, you're weighting
in such a way that you have to be picking up
things you've gotten wrong in the past. So in other words,
it's not enough to say, only the things that are
hard in the last set, are the ones that I
have to do better. You must also be picking up
some of the things that you've gotten wrong earlier more
than you were getting right. Because there's just not enough
information in the one's that you're getting right all the
time, because by the time you get that far along,
the weight on them is near zero and they don't matter.
>> Interesting.
>> And then if you say, well, Charles,
I could cycle back by always getting those wrong,
yes, but then if you're getting those wrong, they're going to
pull up and you're going to have to start getting
those right too. And so, over time, you've gotta not
just pick out things that do better than a
half. But things that do well on a lot of
the data. Because there's no way for all of the
possible distributions for you to do better than chance otherwise.
>> Cool.